ongoing
a good time
I'm the walk that move
Oh
April twelfth saw the release of
fallouts new dlc wasteland workshop as
the name suggests this new content
focuses on the workshop element of the
game adding a number of new world
objects and the ability to build arenas
to staged fights capture and pacify
animals or just add a little bit of
color to your settlements fallouts
workshop feature was one of my favorite
things about fallout 4 so hopefully the
thursda keeps injecting it with new
features and additions to really allow
you to build the settlement of your
dreams it's a shame I'm not the most
creative of individuals so instead i
spent about 30 minutes just labeling
random things in sanctuary with pretty
neon signs at least preston is sleeping
in the right place there's also a new
selection of traps to improve your
defenses or if you're like me you can
just start pretending you're the
antagonist from saw spring-loaded traps
crab doors pressure plates with awfully
plays spikes and even spinning saw
blades I'd like to play a game the main
spectacle comes from the ability to
create your own fights to the death like
a futuristic irradiated version of
gladiator with less walking slowly
through wheat fields the wake reach
capturing works is that you must set up
a cage for your new furry friend make
sure it has power and then play the
waiting game usually about 24 in game
hours away from the location of a cage
then you can return cut the power and
release whatever beast may be within and
watch the ensuing spectacle I found it
more fun to see how much chaos they can
cause before being taken down by each
other or your settlers the creatures you
can capture vary from the very small and
I think from cats and dogs to the much
larger deathclaws and yogg wise and I'm
not sure how but it seems that Raiders
and Gunners are both stupid enough to
fall for the very very obvious traps but
my favorite part the DLC is the arena
teams if you assign a settler to a color
marker then they join that team and will
attack anyone from the opposing side
this is most satisfying to set up when
there are particular settlers that annoy
you or you can use it to just allow your
companions to settle some scores just in
case you've been wondering who would win
in a fight between strong and paladin
dance then well wonder no more just make
sure you're clear the collateral damage
if you've been toying with waistline
workshop then we would love to see some
screenshots of your creations so tweet
the mass using the hashtag GS fallout
and until next week stay safe out there
wastelander
you